bien en este vídeo trabajamos con la
función fx que va a ser igual a x
cuadrada más x menos 6 sobre todo esto
sobre x menos 2 y lo curioso aquí sería
ver qué pasa para el límite de fx cuando
x se aproxima a 2 y checar a que es
igual esto ahora lo que podríamos hacer
es preguntarnos o decir qué pasa o qué
ocurre con efe de 2 éste siempre será el
límite para el cual nos interesa puesto
que en este punto cuando xe aproximados
está indefinido para visualizar lo que
ocurre hay que hacer lo siguiente
entonces tomando o evaluando
efe de 2 en esta función y sustituyendo
la digamos que sería x cuadrada más x
entonces tendríamos 2 al cuadrado más 2
menos 6 y esto da igual a 0 y abajo sea
2 menos 20 entonces para esto la función
no está definida que es para cuando x es
igual a 2 entonces en este caso decimos
que ésta
definida y hasta ahorita todo esto
parece bastante simple y bueno ahora
también es un tanto evidente puesto que
cuando una función es continua y sacamos
su límite es el valor al que se está
aproximando así de sencillo y en este
caso nos podemos dar cuenta fácilmente
que esta función no es continua puesto
que tiene un punto en el que está
indefinido así que ahora veamos si
podemos simplificar la función y es
simplemente un binomio al cuadrado
entonces hay que buscar un par de
números que multiplicados nos den menos
6 y al sumarlos nos den 1 y en este caso
podría ser más 3 y menos 2 y como podrás
darte cuenta aquí en este caso podemos
cancelar en esta parte de nuestra de
nuestro cociente el x menos 2 y
simplemente nos queda x + 3 para el caso
en el que las x sean distintas a 2 para
todas x distintas de 2 y ahora esta es
una forma diferente de escribir nuestra
función pero simplemente es
y utilizar el color azul para realizarlo
entonces tenemos que fx es igual a x + 3
para el x distintas de 2 y está
indefinido para x igualados y si estoy
reescribiendo y diciendo esta definición
de fx es porque yo siento que es mucho
más clara y la podemos graficar más
fácilmente entonces digamos que por aquí
tenemos nuestro ex eje de las de fx efe
de xy por acá tenemos nuestro eje de las
y al haberlo definido así sabemos que la
función es x 3 excepto para x igual a 2
entonces esta sería prácticamente
nuestra función identidad recorrida 3
puntos hacia arriba en nuestro eje de
las 10 entonces esto sería excepto para
cuando x es igual a 2 entonces aquí
tenemos 1 y 2 y por aquí voy a escribir
el espacio que está indefinido para
nuestra función y entonces se comporta
algo así es como la identidad recorrida
así luce fx pero bueno ahora que ya
tenemos nuestra gráfica de fx vamos a
tratar de responder nuestra pregunta
cuál sería el límite o cuál es el límite
de fx nuestra función para cuando x se
aproxima a 2 y lo podemos ver
gráficamente conforme x toma valores muy
cercanos a este aquí está el 2 entonces
digamos que tomamos un valor de 1.7 y
entonces f x se refleja
acá luego un valor de 1.9 y si te das
cuenta tiende a acercarse demasiado a
este valor donde tenemos la parte
indefinida y luego qué tal si del lado
derecho decimos que por aquí tenemos a
2.5 entonces su gráfica se ve reflejada
por acá más bien su f x y luego si
tuviéramos 2.1 también veríamos que se
comporta de esta forma y tienden a
acercarse a este punto que son las
flechas que estoy poniendo una es por la
parte positiva cuando nos acercamos en
dirección de la derecha y la otra flecha
es en cuanto nos acercamos a la
izquierda entonces este límite tiende a
ese punto ahora va yendo la función qué
pasaría si decimos que punto que la
función está definida para x igualados a
sustituirla nos queda un valor de 5 pues
dos más 13 5 entonces estos en realidad
están acercándose o aproximándose a
dicho valor al punto al punto que
tenemos aquí que sería 5 ahora podemos
tratar con esto numéricamente entonces
haciendo esto vamos a tener lo siguiente
vamos a
próxima valores por la izquierda y por
la derecha a 2 y vamos a ver qué pasa
entonces digamos que vamos a tomar 1.99
de 999 que es un número realmente
cercano a 2 entonces al sumar se lo a 3
1.993 vemos que es un valor también muy
aproximado a 5 entonces nos queda 4.999
y ahora dándole un valor de de 2.001 más
3 y vemos que es un valor muy aproximado
a 5 sin embargo ninguno de los 12 5
finalmente observando esto gráficamente
o numéricamente se ve claro o es
evidente que el límite de aquí será
igual a 5 y con esto terminamos